قد صرحانا مقترحات موسكو بشان ما سماه نزع
السلاح والقضاء على النزعه النازيه في
اوكرانيا حسب تعبيره معروفه تماما لدى
كياف
ونقلت وكاله الانباء الروسيه الرسميه
الى التحرك للقضاء على تهديده اند روسيا
والا فان الجيش الروسي هو الذي سيحسم
الامر وفقا تعبير
منك
كيف رؤيه كيف لهذا المؤتمر الذي تقول بان
تسعى لترتيبه في فبراير للسلام مؤتمر
السلام ولكن بشروطها كما
بالفعل عبد الصمد رؤيه كيف هي وفقا للمقاس
الاوكراني للشروط الاوكرانيه في الوقت
الذي يتحدث في وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني عن
محادثات للسلامه وخطه لمحادثات للسلام
الرئيس الاوكراني خلال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني كان يتحدث عن ذلك الرئيس
الاوكراني خلال الساعات الماضيه بعد حديث
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه يتحدث عن
استمرار القتال يتحدث عن جبهات مفتوحه في
الشرق والغرب ويتحدث ايضا عن خطه مقابله
خطه مقابله لمواصله القتال من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه للعام المقبل و يتحدث ايضا عن
انه اجتمع مع كبار القاده السياسيين
والعسكريين لبحث التسريع خطوات
الوصول المساعدات الامريكيه تحديدا
المساعدات العسكريه همم الى همم ثياب والى
مواقع الجبهات في اكثر من مقاطعه جنوبيه
وشرقيه وزير خارجيه الاوكراني كان في
حديثه يوم امس عندما قال بان هذه الخطه
لاطلاق محادثات للسلام وفضل ان تكون
برعايه الامم المتحده وفي الامم المتحده
اشار بشكل واضح دون لبس بان هذه الخطه
وفقا للشروط الاوكرانيه الشروط الاوكرانيه
التي كان قدمها الرئيس الاوكراني خلال
الفتره الماضيه وهي تنطلق من 10 نقاط تبدا
من رفع ما تسميه كيف الحصار الفوري عن همم
موانئها البحريه هو النهريه مرورا
يعني رفع او همم اطلاق همم او ابتعاد
القوات الروسيه عن محطه
الطاقه النوويه وصولا الى تعويض يعني
تعويض مباشر لكيف لتعويض مادي من قبل
روسيا عن الاضرار التي همم الحرب بالاضافه
الى يعني مغادره الاراضي الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والتسليم بوحده الاراضي
الاوكرانيه في الدنباز في الشرق في الجنوب
بالاضافه الى شبه جزيره القرم التي تعتبر
يعني وفقا لروسيا اراضي روسيا هذه النقاط
التي تتحدث عنها وزاره الخارجيه وقبل ذلك
صباح هذا اليوم او بعد ذلك كان مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني يتحدث بشكل واضح بان ضرب
العمق ال- ال- الروسي والاختراقات ما
وصفها بالاختراقات التي تجري داخل الاراضي
الروسيه في اشاره الى همم استهداف القاعده
همم الروسيه يوم امس في العمق الروسي تعكس
عدم سيطره عدم قدره موسكو على الامساك
بازمام الامور داخل الجبهات داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اذا اللغه مختلفه كثيرا وهنالك
حاله من التشدد الكبير ونهايه ازدهار
هنالك ايضا دعوات من البرلمان الاوكراني
بان لا يتم الحديث عن مفاوضات وعن همم
سلام مرتقب مع التساؤلات
الروس بالتعويض المادي الكامل هؤلاء كثيره
كما ذكرنا مطروحه
تستطيع الامساك من زمام الامور عسكريا
وسياسيا وهنا انتقل اليك امين همم درغامي
تحدى تامر عن المقاصه الاوكراني الشروط
الاوكرانيه ماذا عن الموقف الروسي في ضوء
التصريحات روسيا الاخيره
هذا كان واضحا من خلال تصريحات المتحدث
باسم الكريم لان دي متر بيسكوف الذي قال
بان اهداف روسيا الواضحه وما سماه بالفطره
السليمه هي مرجعيه روسيا لتفاوض وروسيا لا
تقبل من كما قال التفاوض باي شروط من اي
طرف كان ومن هنا يمكن استنتاج على ان
الموقف الروسي همم هذه المبادره لنقل بين
قوسين الاوكرانيه همم ثابت وروسيا ترفض
الدخول في اي مفاوضات بالرغم من انها ترى
همم ترى بان التفاوض لن يتم همم بينها
وبين كيف بشكل مباشر لانها همم حسب النظره
الروسيه كيف همم تخضع لضغوط من قبل
الولايات المتحده وان كانت اي مفاوضات
مستقبليه او اي حوار سواء على حل الازمه
او المس الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه المتعلقه
بالامن الدولي والامن في القاره الاوروبيه
على وجه الخصوصيتم بينها وبين الولايات
المتحده بشكل مباشر وهذا ما اتضح ايضا من
خلال كلام وزير الخارجيه سرجيله ظروف الذي
اقر باستحاله او صعوبه على الاقل التفاوض
مع الولايات المتحده في الوقت الراهن الى
ان تنضج بحسب ما قال الولايات المتحده
لتدرك سلبيات نهجها الحالي
وذلك بسبب توجهات اداره الرئيس الامريكي
جويدا كما قال ظروف لكنه في المقابل ترك
باب الحوار مفتوحا قلبي ان موسكو مستعد
لمناقشه القضايا الامنيه سواء في السياق
اوكرانيا او في السياق القضايا
الاستراتيجيه الامنيه لكن اللافت في
الموقف الروسي اليوم هو التهديد همم اتخاذ
خطوات حازمه لاي مخاطر يمكنها ان تهدد جود
الدوله الروسيه بحسب تلك الاتهامات التي
واجهها الاغروب الى واشنطن وحلفائها بانهم
يحاولون الانخراط بشكل اكبر في الصراع في
اوكرانيا بهدف اضعاف وتدمير همم الدوله
همم الروسيه وقال بان موسكو ستتخذ كل
الاجراءات من اجل تلك المخاطر وهذا يحينا
ايضا ازدهار الى تصريحات الرئيس الاسبوع
المقبل الذي قال بان روسيا مستعده لاتخاد
اي وسائل بما فيها الاسلحه غير التقليديه
من اجل حمايه سيادتها واراضيها وشعبها
وهذا طبعا ايضا يحللنا الى العقيده
النوويه الروسيه لربما وتساؤلات الى اي
مدى يمكن لروسيا همم الذهاب همم باتجاه
همم ما تسميه على الاقل المخاطر المتزايده
القادمه من الغرب من درغامي من مصر
شكرا جزيلا لكم